je précise d'abord que évidemment ce
qu'il a fait terrible il a pris sa
voiture en ayant consommé des
stupéfiants c'est tout ce qu'on sait
pour l'instant il a eu un accident en
ayant consommé des stupéfiants ça ce
sont les fêtes un accident qui a eu les
conséquences que Gilles Verdez vient de
décrire évidemment il est tout à fait
légitime qu'on exprime notre compassion
notre souci de victime maintenant j'ai
depuis l'impression d'insister à la
charge et vous savez ça me fait beaucoup
penser est-ce que vous vous rappelez que
Magnum c'est-à-dire quand les partisans
les plus cinglés de Trump en gros se
sont mis à diffuser des messages
expliquant et beaucoup le croyait que le
monde est dirigé par une élite pédophile
sataniste c'est la décadence le sexe la
drogue on mélange tout on mélange ce qui
est autorisé ce qu'il n'est pas on
mélange ce qu'on sait et ce qu'on ne
sait pas et moi Gilles hier j'étais je
dois dire que j'étais assez choqué par
votre séquence avec Karl Zéro mais je
reconnais qu'il y a beaucoup de
chroniqueurs ici qui ont fait le boulot
ils ont fait le boulot après
Dominique body du même genre de choses
il y a 20 ans je trouve quand même que
ça le disqualifie mais si vous voulez
les conditionnel en ce qui concerne
l'affaire des vidéos pédo
pornographiques ça ne va pas on ne
devrait même pas en parler et est-ce que
vous vous rappelez la chanson
l'Auvergnat de Brassens sur même un
criminel elle est à droite si vous
voulez il fait partie de l'humanité là
j'ai l'impression que Palmade si vous
laissez-le le le mal absolu c'est le
nouveau diable si vous voulez il est
attaqué de partout franchement attaquer
Palma on n'a pas besoin d'être très
courageux aujourd'hui et qu'en plus on
en fait un exemple de ses élites
décadentes et moi le puritanisme et le
complotisme en même temps ça me fait
peur m'a donné quatre boules de bois
quand dans ma vie faisait froid et là
oui et moi j'ai l'impression que les
croquantes et les croquants tous les
gens bien intentionnés si vous voulez
sont très contents
et dans mon
âme il brûle encore à l'arrière d'un
creux de joie exactement
[Musique]
qu'il te conduisent à travers
on va quand même pas pleurer pour pardon
on va quand même pas pleurer pour faire
Palmade c'est-à-dire que lui il est
sorti de l'hôpital il peut marcher il
peut prendre des taxis il y a deux
personnes qui sont dans un état
dramatique il y a un bébé
vous faites de la philosophie en fait
mais les les filles sont là ils sont
très graves et je pense que il y a pas
un lynchage moi je pense qu'il y a une
prise de conscience de l'opinion qui l'a
peut-être certes jugé mais qui a aussi
pris conscience de plein de sujets de
société du danger de l'alcool et de la
drogue au volant du Ken sexe aussi et je
pense qu'on est plus dans la prise de
conscience que dans le lynchage mais on
ne peut pas le soutenir on peut pas
avoir pitié de lui ah bon d'abord le
soutenir avant pitié c'est pas pareil
vous vous pouvez pas et vous me
reprochez de faire de la philosophie ce
qui reçoit me paraît pas mal si vous
voulez mais excusez-moi je le redis on
mélange des choses qu'on sait des choses
qu'on ne sait pas parce que ce qu'il
fait sexuellement avec des adultes ou
s'en fiche c'est son problème tant qu'il
n'est pas au volant qu'il ne met pas
d'autres gens danger c'est son problème
et là on est en train si vous voulez de
monter une sauce en se disant regardez
il y a beaucoup de gens vous savez je
vois sur les réseaux il y a beaucoup de
gens qui en fait pour qui Palmade est
une espèce de sous figure de Macron et
moi divergences politiques avec Emmanuel
Macron mais cette haine si vous voulez
des hélices c'est n'importe quoi non
mais
oui
oui ça c'est n'importe quoi oui ça je
suis d'accord avec vous c'est n'importe
quoi
on entend tout et n'importe quoi
c'est très choqué encore une fois je
partage
complètement la compassion pour les
victimes bien sûr mais j'ai été très
choquée quand vous avez dit oui on m'a
dit qu'il y avait des enfants de gens
puissants mais bon vous vous rendez
compte du fantasme c'est ça vous êtes en
train de nous dire en plus ça je reçois
plein de SMS de gens c'est qui c'est qui
je sais même pas j'ai même pas demandé
des conneries alors moi ce qui me choque
c'est vous
ce qui me choque c'est que dans Causeur
et ailleurs mais donc aux heures votre
revue vous ne parliez pas de cette
affaire sauf erreur de ma part
ça il est sorti avant l'affaire et moi
j'ai une question à vous poser est-ce
que vous n'êtes pas un peu en toute
amitié complaisante avec tout ce qui est
possiblement donc scandale
pédopornographique et réellement la
pédophilie
comment tu peux dire des conneries je
peux même pas finir ma question
comme vous l'avez été avec Gabriel
Madness l'écrivain qui a reconnu ses
penchants pédophiles et on comprend rien
mais si on met une demi-heure je veux
bien vous parler de la personne
je dis que tant que ça n'est pas avéré
ça n'existe pas on ne peut pas prendre
des ragots et des rumeurs pour des
vérités supposer que tout ça soit
démenti vous croyez que les gens il y a
une vidéo vous l'avez vu vous savez
qu'il en face c'est incroyable c'est
comme ça que vous traitez les affaires
judiciaires
moi je suis d'accord avec votre
diagnostic global mais je suis pas
d'accord avec vos conclusions moi je
pense que justement c'est un fait divers
majeur c'est un électrochoc pour
l'époque et c'est totalement c'est une
sorte d'étude sociologique de l'époque
qui dépasse exactement d'abord c'est le
c'est le nanti c'est le mec célèbre
c'est le mec qui était dans la lumière
et tout d'un coup il y a l'an il y a le
réfugié il y a l'exilé politique comme
ça qui va être frappé comme ça la
victime qui va être à l'hôpital et qui
va mourir avec le mec très célèbre qui
finalement va s'en sortir non mais
globalement
en tout cas il est vivant il n'a pas de
séquelles donc ça c'est la première
chose ensuite c'est la sphère
complotiste vous avez vu hier c'est mais
on nous dit pas tout on nous cache il y
avait qui dans la maison il y a
forcément en fait c'est je trouve que
c'est un fait divers hyper révélateur de
l'époque comme à l'époque ça a été avec
Dominique strauss-kah et si on le
traitait comme ça ça ne me dérange c'est
pas c'est pas le fait qu'on prenne le
truc comme ça on nourrit ce complotisme
je parle pas de la musique générale non
parce que hier il y a il y a des gens
qui vont dans dans ce côté-là complet
c'est puis Anna comme Valérie
Géraldine c'est que quand Gilles et
pardon Gilles mais soi-disant pas tu es
journaliste et tu donnes des cours de
journalisme dit il se dit il y a des
rumeurs à ce qui paraît que ce serait
des fils de ministre de machin c'est du
journalisme il y a des rumeurs à ce
qu'il paraît
c'était exactement pareil avec
d'ailleurs c'est les mêmes qui dit ça
que ceux qui étaient contre le vaccin
mais on n'est pas obligé d'être d'accord
avec son époque on a le droit d'être
minoritaire
le problème je trouve assez que vous
arrêtez ça fait trois fois que vous
dites c'est un accident non un accident
c'est quelqu'un de pile le bar il arrive
il rentre dedans donc le pare-choc ça
c'est un accident quand on prend sa
voiture sous le terrain de stupéfiant
qu'on sait qu'on risque de d'en faire en
courir des dangers
c'est plus un accident
[Applaudissements]
de prendre leur voiture en ayant bu un
verre de trop en ayant consommé des gens
et qui ont eu la chance qui ont eu la
chance d'accord de ne pas benjaminer
cette fragile de ne pas comprendre
ce qu'il appelle j'ai commencé par cela
et bien mais ils n'en reste pas moins
d'accord que ça n'est pas la et quand il
n'y a pas de raison d'être plus sévère
avec lui il y avait des boyaux
on a décidé pour sa carrière de se
placer sur la place publique on est
traité sur la place publique compta
c'est une violence
de société
l'idée qu'un artiste doit être
exemplaire allait donc en parler à ça
des artistes exemplaires ça franchement
il faut vraiment rien connaître à
l'histoire de l'art pour penser qu'un
artiste est exemplaire
quand même
non mais non mais c'est un exemple pour
plein de gens c'est un artiste non mais
blague d'accord donc on est artiste donc
on fait n'importe quoi et le talent
vient de ça je suis pas d'accord avec
simplement
c'est inhérent à son statut c'est une
personnalité publique donc le public
s'en empare
l'espèce de il y a une grosse caisse qui
tape tout le monde qui tape les mêmes
marteaux des milliers de marteaux tapent
sur le même coup mais il y a est-ce que
il y a quelques jours qui a un moment
une lumière qui s'allume on vous dites
bon il a le droit aussi à une défense
oui mais Elisabeth
un être humain un être humain qui a voté
reste un être humain
est-ce que je vois c'est un flot de
haine comme si si vous voulez Palma
d'été devenu l'incarnation du mal il a
fauté évidemment et j'ai commencé par
cela et j'ai commencé
gênant
mais qu'est-ce que vous voulez que je
dise là où moi je suis d'accord avec
vous c'est que effectivement il y a un
lynchage aujourd'hui qui fait que il a
une double peine non seulement la
première peine c'est que jusqu'à sa mort
il ne pourra jamais racheter la
culpabilité qu'il a et il aura la boule
au ventre tous les jours de sa vie
jusqu'à ce qu'il meurt en plus de ce qui
va recevoir mais bien sûr il a commis un
crime et donc ça c'est sûr la maman
[Musique]
pour confondrez la justice et la
bande-annonce donc cette maman ayant
beaucoup souffert évidemment et c'est
terrible donc ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire que la justice c'est la vengeance
non non non non non
selon les articles va être handicapés
peut-être avis le fils handicapé à vie
et la mère qui a perdu son arme quelque
part un peu son mari un peu son fils et
totalement son enfant c'est un drame
total tout à fait d'accord je l'ai dit
oui c'est juste à l'accident
total cette famille
donc considérer qu'un être humain qui a
commis quelque chose de très grave reste
un être humain
je vous invite alors à réécouter cette
chanson quand même comment ça n'est pas
une version quand même merci j'ai pas
dit est-ce que j'ai prononcé ce mot
merci Elisabeth regardez je sais je suis
très minoritaire